the next frontier for human spaceflight
is obvious we have to go to Mars you
might have heard a lot of people talking
about this recently from tech innovators
NASA scientists even President Obama has
made the case that we should go to Mars
so we talked to Chris McKay a senior
scientist at NASA's Ames Research Center
and he's involved in the planning of
future Mars missions and he walked us
through some of the hazards
I'm Brian Resnick I'm a science reporter
at Vox I will never go to Mars and here
are the top seven reasons why here's
number one your rocket could blow up
before leaving Earth this is pretty
obvious nASA has a pretty good track
record with sending astronauts to space
but we also know that there have been
tragedies for some context the NASA
space shuttle program carried 833 people
to orbit between 1981 and 2011 of which
14 people died in two big explosions
SpaceX has a checkered history of trying
to launch rockets and land them number
two so if you successfully leave Earth
and it's all safe and it's all good
there's still some dangers in that
journey to Mars
the biggest danger here is radiation
exposure the vacuum of space
is not really empty there's radiation
emanating from the Sun it goes out in
all directions there are gamma rays and
x-rays and ultraviolet light and all
these things that can damage our cells
so here on earth we have a dense
atmosphere in a magnetic field that
helps keep this radiation out of our
daily lives according to measurements
from NASA's Curiosity rover there's more
radiation at the surface of Mars and
there would be on earth perhaps a more
worrisome risk of radiation in space is
from solar flares so occasionally and
randomly in a way that's hard to predict
the Sun emits very large batches of
radiation in great flares number three
you can crash on Mars surface trying to
land one thing about
on Mars that the atmosphere is a lot
thinner that means there's a lot less of
a cushion another way to think about it
is there's a lot less friction in the
atmosphere that will naturally slow your
spacecraft down basically you would need
a system of rockets to help you land
smoothly on Mars we saw with the
Curiosity rover that was an incredibly
intricate and choreographed maneuver to
get just that one ton rover down onto
the planet could you imagine getting 6 7
10 100 humans down onto that planet you
would need a very complicated very
sophisticated and very well tested
system to help people descend down to
the Martian surface number 4
Mars is low gravity might wreak havoc on
your bones and muscles many astronauts
who spend six months or more on the
space station have vision loss that
doesn't get corrected when they come
back down to the earth
there was one astronaut that went from
perfect 20/20 vision to 2100 vision just
in six months other things that happen
in the microgravity of space is that
your muscles start to deteriorate your
bones start to deteriorate and this can
be saved off by some regular exercise
but NASA really hasn't found a complete
solution to this problem and think about
a six month voyage to Mars you know once
you get there the Martian gravity isn't
as strong as Earth's it's not as light
as you would be on the moon it's not as
heavy as you would be on earth so will
muscles and bones and eyesight
continue to deteriorate on Mars is not
yet known number five your spacesuit or
habitat could leak and you just can't
breathe Martian air pressure of Mars
atmosphere is just a fraction of the
pressure of Earth's atmosphere your
house and Mars would be like the cabin
of an airplane any crack in your house
any slit in your spacesuit will lead it
to depressurize and that's who that's
the obvious problem
the Mars is filled with dust and dirt
that just gets everywhere it could
quickly clog all of your intake vents
could quickly destroy some of your
electronics and people could die if you
inhale it so the dream is that one day
we could potentially Bree of Martian air
this is an idea that has long obsessed
science fiction authors it's called
terraforming and the idea is that maybe
we can change the Martian atmosphere to
be more like Earth we could start some
global warming on Mars and raise the
temperature of the planet and entrap
more greenhouse gases in we can raise
the level of co2 so we can start growing
plants there those plants could then
start produce oxygen this is probably
the most far-fetched idea out there not
to say it's impossible but just it is
well well into the future
number six the planet Mars could
literally kill you the soil of Mars is
toxic you might have seen the movie the
Martian where astronaut Mark Watney
grows potatoes on Mars and the Martian
soil we probably shouldn't do that it
contains very high concentrations of
chemicals called perchlorates these are
salts that can do serious damage to the
human body especially the thyroid you
wouldn't want to grow your potatoes in
it it's okay to get Martian dirt on your
hands but you really wouldn't want it to
get into your drinking water or food or
get into your habitat number seven your
fellow travelers could drive you crazy
so this has been a surprising challenge
for NASA to learn and to get over like
how do you craft a crew for a spaceship
that will be alone with each other for
months on end and also be the only human
beings on an entire planet for perhaps
months or years and spending only their
time with one another if there's going
to be a mutiny or if there's going to be
interpersonal strife on Mars
that is a element that could be the
riskiest of all there is this project
called biosphere 2 in 1994 it's living
it was supposed to be like living in a
space colony it was a seven-person crew
and they split it up into warring
factions and the mission had to end
prematurely so it will take some
calibration to find who are the right
people for this type of mission the
first people who go to Mars should go
with the expectation that they might
never come back but that hasn't stopped
explorers for centuries there's always
going to be a drive in humans
to go places we've never been before and
for the most part that drive is
something that has aided our survival at
times so will the risks on a trip to
Mars be great
absolutely should we go absolutely